hi everyone i'm laureation a customer
engineer at google cloud and i'm erica
chong a partner engineer at google cloud
welcome back to another segment of
google cloud technical guides for
startups
in this video we'll be focusing on
continuous integration and continuous
deployment also known as ci cd using
google cloud
in this episode we're going to cover
what is cicd cicd and practice setting
up ci cicd as well as a google cloud
console demo so without any further ado
let's get right into exploring the
google cloud platform together
continuous integration or ci is the
process of automating the building and
testing of changes to code in order to
detect problems early continuous
delivery or cd is the process of
automating deployments across multiple
environments in a safe low risk and
quick manner
let's take a deeper look into each
ci again continuous integration is the
process where code changes undergo a
series of automated processes to ensure
that the application or system is still
working
part of the ci pipeline may be to build
or compile an application once the code
changes have been made in order to
validate and ensure there are no
breaking changes this can be achieved
through a shared repository where
developers commit and merge code that is
then saved reviewed and tested
additional steps can be included and
automated such as unit tests integration
tests and deployment of the same
artifact you should have some sort of
tool for source code management such as
cloud source repositories github or
bitbucket
you can also have a ci server for
building and testing codes such as cloud
build jenkins or circleci with
continuous delivery deploying artifacts
from your ci server must be done
manually
with cd or continuous deployment on the
other hand this is the practice of
delivering new software features through
an automated deployment process
usually run after ci cd may take the
built artifact and use one of the many
different deployment paradigms to deploy
the artifact everything is fully
automated and having every single commit
to your source code management system
built into the artifacts and then
deployed to production some common tools
for continuous deployment include puppet
jenkins and bash scripts
now that we've gone through what
continuous integration and continuous
deployment are you may be wondering why
there's such important concepts to apply
first they ensure that all changes to
code are tracked tested and built
documentation is key so there are no
questions as to what features are in
each release and who made the changes
second automating a lot of these manual
tasks reduces chances of human error
going back to the importance of
documentation should there be any sort
of bugs these will be easily trackable
and you can quickly roll back to a
stable version to reduce any outages
from deployments this leads to increased
innovation and faster time to market
resulting in happier deployment
development and operations teams with cd
oftentimes teams embrace the concept of
immutable infrastructure when delivering
an artifact you can rest assured that
each artifact is exactly the same after
initial deployment no additional
configuration is performed on the vms
and containers thus making the fleet
completely standardized
for vms you can use packer to
automatically perform this build and
versioning and for kubernetes and
containers you can use docker
as a result you'll get faster times
for launch to images and containers as
they're pre-baked with all software and
configurations
in practice it looks something like this
we have a new binary or configuration to
deploy we must first bake a deployable
image based on a full build of a server
here we install all runtime dependencies
such as runtime stacks and of course our
application binary
you can automate this in any way that
you'd like such as using chef puppet or
another tool
we then deployed this image
as a vm instance in our various
environments that we test in through to
production where we can deploy the same
image again
if you're using docker containers this
is a very familiar territory for you and
where you can bake images via docker
build or server side build services such
as docker hub and google container
registry builds
if you're deploying to vms spin acres
packer based bakeries that can support
the flow that i just described
there are other benefits that are
particularly pertinent as you're
deploying to the cloud if your chef reps
bees for example are taking 40 minutes
to complete the build of a new server
you're not able to take advantage of the
elasticity of the cloud the demand has
already come and passed other ops
critical functions such as auto healing
and rollback images are similarly very
difficult if you're not using these
pre-baked images another product to
highlight is google cloud deploy google
cloud deploy allows users to deliver
continuously to google kubernetes engine
or gke within minutes there are many
benefits of this managed service first
users don't have to own scale and or
maintain cd tooling themselves
similar to cloud build google cloud
deploy is a managed service this reduces
the total cost of ownership for
continuous delivery there are no servers
to manage or patch and resources can
scale up and down automatically to
optimize cost and performance
it also integrates with google cloud
platform's identity and access
management and has audit features built
in
this easily enables the securing
tracking and auditing of delivery
pipelines and related activities
google cloud deploys opinionation aims
to reduce onboarding time and cost of
ownership by providing structure to
continuous delivery processes
you can define releases and progress
them through environments such as test
stage and production and there's a
one-step promotion and rollback of
releases via the web console cli or api
in addition there is built-in support
for metrics to measure and optimize
deployment success with increased
visibility users can gain insights on
deployment metrics and drive objective
based sre and devops processes
this is an example of an end-to-end ci
cd workflow the first step for a ci cd
pipeline is to host your code in a
source control management system such as
google cloud source repositories
once you upload your code to your
repository we'll have to choose from one
of many platforms designed to facilitate
ci cd
many common platforms were designed to
run all kinds of automation and have
since been adjusted to support ci cd
google cloud build was designed with ci
cd in mind and is serverless meaning you
don't have to manage the underlying
infrastructure of your builds you can
configure google cloud build with
cloudbuild.yaml files that live directly
in your repository
cloudbuild facilitates ci by supporting
many different source control services
easy integration with google cloud
services for testing and it supports
deploying artifacts to various
destinations including artifact registry
cloud build supports complex builds with
multiple steps for example testing and
deployments if you want to add to your
ci pipeline it's as easy as adding an
additional step to it
take your artifact either built or
stored locally or at your destination
and easily deploy it to one of our many
compute services with a deployment
strategy of your choice
now let's take a look into how we can
create a deployment pipeline for cloud
run that implements progression of code
from developer branches with automated
canary testing in google cloud platform
cloudron lets you deploy and run your
applications with little overhead or
effort
check out the cloud run video in the
description box below just to get a
quick stream through of the cloud run
and other compute services available in
google cloud platform
in this demo we will create a sample
cloud run service
add a change on the development branch
merge the branch into the main line
branch
implement canary testing to roll out the
new change to the cloud run service
let's start off
is preparing our environment
let's go to google cloud console
and login into google cloud project in
the console we activate cloud shell
and now let's create environmental
variables
and enable the needed apis
if they are not enabled
and now let's set up the admin roles for
service accounts
if you haven't used git in cloud shell
previously
you can set up the user name and user
email values
and now we will clone and prepare the
sample repository
we will store the code from sample
repository in cloud source repositories
all right now let's move to the cloud
run service
in cloud shell we will build and deploy
the application including a service that
requires identification
the next step is to enable a unique url
for development branches in git
each branch is represented by url that's
identified by the branch name
commits to the branch trigger deployment
and the updates are accessible at the
same url
in cloud shell let's set up a trigger
now let's create a new branch and open
the sample application into cloud shell
in the sample application let's modify
the code to indicate version 1.1 instead
of version 1.0
and now let's commit the change and push
this remote repository
you can check the progress of ongoing
build in the cloud builder
cloud build can also trigger a message
via email slug or other messaging
providers
now let's get the unique url for this
branch
when code is released to production it's
common to release code to small subset
of live traffic before migrating the
traffic to the new code basis
let's implement a trigger that is
activated when code is committed to the
main branch the trigger deploys the code
to unicanner url and it wrote 10 of all
live traffic to the new version
all right let's set up the branch
trigger
and now merge the branch to the main
line and push to the remote repository
after the build is complete let's renew
the new version
as you see 90 of the traffic is routed
to prod
10 to canary
and zero percent to the branch revisions
that brings us to the end of this video
where we went over
what is the icd ci cd in practice
setting up cicd deployment strategies
and a google cloud consult email we have
tons of resources and guides around
setting up cacd on our documentation
website
a couple of resources have been added in
the description box below to help you
understand these concepts in further
detail
i encourage you to take a look prior to
setting everything up
should you run into any issues our
support team is always available as well
stay tuned for all the exciting content
that we have for you
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our youtube channel click on the bell
icon to get notified each time a new
video is posted
we will see you soon in our next video
where we will go over different
operations and billing tools in google
cloud
thank you and see you next time
[Music]